good we'll hunt is honestly seemed like
that snippet of a moment I would just
like men's I think out of any movie here
that's why the one I relate with the
most because I've been in therapy for
many years and I've had my breakthroughs
and I've never had like there's a pretty
complicated relationship with my pair
yeah I've never had like this dynamic
where I'm like resistant against my
therapist like that most of my session
what's going on reject nation Craig help
accuse John here we just did a video for
patreon where you know I teared up quite
a bit actually looking over the footage
as you do and I thought why not keep the
tradition of crying going that I'll cry
here one of our reward tiers on a
certain patreon pledge is whatever you
request we will do and put it up on
YouTube whether it be a video topic or
reacting and discussing the video and
today's and your Terpening special video
requests top ten guy cry movies oh yeah
here we go this list is from watch of
the Mojo a.com see if I cried at any of
these welcome to watchmojo.com and today
we're counting down our picks for the
top 10 guy guy movies
Victoria gets to do people with new
videos every day my friends will be sure
to subscribe for more great content for
this list we're taking a look at films
that we feel are the most effective at
hitting all the right notes to break
down the typical macho male stereotypes
and then demonstrate that men you have a
soft side to bready dudes watching you
worn these slits will probably make you
fall into your pillow all night long
also spoiler is Morgan I don't ever you
haven't seen this you know what happens
look it's better this way that's a guy
cry man sure would have expected a movie
about an aged Mutant with razor sharp
claws and a wicked temper to hit us
right in the field well thanks to
director James Nagel the smart decision
to never wait from super heroics
for a more personal tale about the
family and redemption the third solo
Wolverine clip was just as emotionally
moving as it was extremely violent
whether you have tears of joy from
seeing Logan's triumphant Berserker ages
one last time or are bowling from the
loving bond rates of flora this is one
comic book movie that tugs the
heartstrings far more than any of it oh
yeah
number nine Yuri is set to boy every
time every time Oh after the tragic
death of Paul Walker the seventh film in
this franchise was the way in order to
give the loved ones time to mourn and
the filming is time to decide how to
respectfully continue without the acted
alongside the movie's resident Eames
about the importance of family and
friendship the final scene particular
packs one heck of a heart-wrenching calm
as we see DOM and Brian driving
alongside each other on an open road
retreated to flashbacks at times the two
shared in Prior films paying tribute to
both the character and Paul Walker
himself in indicating that his memory
will never die as they do some that see
with number eight Rudy
possibly can which apparently we all
have a dream and that's what makes this
film based on a true story so powerful
Rudy wants nothing more than to play
football at the University of Notre Dame
despite the series of overwhelming odds
and unexpected roadblocks it can't kind
of jump I didn't produce results doesn't
mean anything as we watch Rudy struggled
to convince the school to admit him we
really begin to feel for his hardship
while simultaneously rooting for him
based on his undying determination
riri-chan I'm ready for this my whole
life once read he finally achieves what
you wanted to do don't be surprised if
you find yourself standing and cheering
for his accomplishment it's me all those
words it going and the rewarding
projects upon achieve
[Music]
number seven The Green Mile sirens
camera for an African cinema the concept
of a personal journey during life in
prison isn't a new one as it's being
done several times in movies as in the
other Stephen King tale the
oscar-nominated the Shawshank Redemption
however we argue that the Green Mountain
livers it's heartfelt message more
effectively much of this can be
attributed to stellar performances from
Tom Hanks and Michael Clarke Duncan off
as we watch their characters bond and
share their personal experiences and
perspectives the subject matter is dark
but if the film successfully teaches us
anything it's how to hold on to hope
even in the dyers of situations if
that's not worthy of shedding a tear or
two what is number six warrior warrior
forgive me okay pop brothers fight it's
just simply nature but they have us wear
off in a brutal traps or her establishes
that the relationship between brothers
Tommy and Brendan
it wasn't exactly being all that
buddy-buddy with a great deal of
distance created between them over the
years
despite their estranged family dynamics
as well as the dozens of punches and
kicks they talks at each other's faces
these two brothers managed to put their
differences aside and realize how much
they actually care for what it counts
back on his bad way of the unconditional
love found in Brotherhood and packs
quite the punch
number five Forrest Gump well you ain't
seen I am seeing harness come to my mom
problems feature agree my horse gun
struggles and triumphs supports Gump is
enough to make even the most Stuart
burly man behold his eyes out Tom Hanks
is no stranger to emotionally-charged
built like the epic drama castaway heard
in performances mr. Gump
a man born a little different but still
with a heart of gold who's trying to
find his place in the world that hits
way hard weather forces explain Tom
meeting his son or summing up life of a
box of chocolates
this man brings us some valuable life
lessons and we should bring along some
tissues number four in step is Moore's
awakens reaction to find a new planet
for Humanity to call home
Sigmund Hoover has to leave his family
behind which includes his young daughter
Burke with whom he shares an incredibly
strong bond any Father's watching would
feel the weight of having to leave their
child for a greater good or you know
more salt in the wound
Cooper receives video messages from
earth and witness all the events number
three Good Will Hunting spider-man well
what am I afraid in this extremely
personal stories about finding your
place in the world
I'm sure fallen from the hardships of
life there's no shortage of moments to
send waterfalls flowing out from your
eyes I'm pumped so the healing begin as
we
more about wills many difficulties in
life we feel more connected with him and
whatever pain he goes through and me
fully sympathizing take your pick the
status see but most would agree it's the
powers we acted and written it's not
your fault sequence
hush never you know the best part of my
day is for about 10 seconds from number
two Brian saw I love all of you to
sports are recognized for developing
friendships and bringing people together
despite difficulties of modern life
nowhere is this more evident than in
Brian saw an ABC TV movie that was later
released in theaters wow that's making a
good movie based in the mid-60s when
racial tension was highly prevalent
within American society football players
Brian and Gayle shatter all societal
norms of their day by forming an
unbreakable friendship
despite the colors of their skin I am
their shared connection served as a
symbol of civility and harmony in an era
that otherwise frowned upon it as they
stayed by one another side through all
trials and tribulations including Brian
developing cancer now that's a true
bromance right there before we reveal
our top pick your honorable mentions
bring assumes traveling into the heavy
[Music]
this man we don't want to make
transformers Eliza
[Music]
he's everyone like funniest movers
dreams have you know the dream number
one huh
Iowa barber ray Kinsella is a simple man
one day here's forces or GM to build
something which rate interprets as a
baseball field he sets up a baseball
diamond did his cornfield and before he
knows it
baseball starts at the past like she was
Joe Jackson visit yet but she was Joe
Jackson this week despite others
taunting him and the fact that it
threatens to send him into bankruptcy
ray maintains the field in the end this
field allows brain to learn more about
himself than he ever imagined as well as
providing him the chance to introduce
his daughter to her grandfather as he
ends up being one of the many visitors
on the field
they occur
do you agree with our kids check out
these other great clips from WatchMojo
aid subscribe Oh pursuit of happiness
that's one that definitely makes me cry
firstly the happinesses is the one which
was on this list the two movies that
definitely make me cry every time but
that's not necessarily like a guide
movie like that's it's kind of a just a
general drunk it's like one of my guide
cry movies is the grey that movies like
oh yes Henson it was more about the
characters and I was expecting from the
dress oh yeah by the time you get to
Revenge of the Fallen
yeah totally I'm an optimist again his
ass kicked the Shia LaBeouf red eyes you
know never fully tearing let's talk
about some of these movies right here
films cry out it's a good list it's a
good lecture la people don't like
WatchMojo anymore these days I don't
know why Logan yeah you know I get hurt
I cried more the second time I saw it
the first time I saw it I didn't really
cry I was definitely impact and I love
this [ __ ] out of the entirety of that
film I didn't really cry I do remember
though John doesn't really I feel like
I'm more likely to cry than John nine
times out of ten I cry more now than I
used to but I remember watching Logan
and that ending scene when he's alone
he's holding Laura's hand here two dudes
to my left you had answered a lot of
simple I just hear you guys it was a
moment in my life where I was like is
there something wrong with me why am I
not in then I cry more than these two
combined one of those people was like no
to make me cry and now I've let go of
that considerable ya know ass and now
it's become an argument like you're weak
right I tried but I had more motions are
you alright right now just cuz we're
arguing in a hurry
furious circus of that scene
the thing about Furious 7 is I think you
have to have investment in the franchise
and you have to be aware of Paul
Walker's actual passing like like I'm
wondering if like 30 years from now if
when people watched like the revisit
Furious 7 or like people who are like 15
by the time 30 years ago if they watch
it will they cry if you're like
especially when the film came out people
were crying I was bald what I see the
moment seen that scene twice and every
time I see you that cry I feel like
it'll still be impactful but I do think
the context and growing up knowing Paul
Yeager is kind of integral to that yeah
exactly it's not someone from people who
don't grow up with the fast movies or
don't grow up with Paul Walker who might
not even know that he died yeah
will they be like as affected by that
moment or they're gonna be like what's
up with this goodbye see you know like
at a context it's a little bit like
what's going on where to go yeah where
to go what's going on with the sinners
day did he die I could see why it's
higher up on the list is I think easily
if we're gonna take these 10 movies this
is one of the top two that makes me cry
a lot and this one became a guy cry
movie because of outside circumstance
sure it's not about it's not about the
context of the film yeah yeah it's like
if he hadn't passed then this would just
be another yeah rollicking adventure who
wouldn't have gotten Scott Eastwood and
life would have been a lot better Rudy I
saw when I was a little kid I don't
really remember it I remember Seagal
chanting Rudy I don't know if I would
cry watching Rudy but I feel like that's
a good example of a guy cry movies I
feel like sports isn't easy guy cry
yeah there's two movies that were
featured here that I don't I like I have
a list all my notes on this computer I
have a list of films I must watch
because I keep getting crap for not
having seen them it's not one of the
ones on the list but they do mention it
Shawshank Redemption I'm so glad I
didn't spoil it cuz it's been so many
years I've had a chance to see this
movie they still haven't seen it
we'll do a double feature will do Green
Mile and Shashi the Green Mile I'm glad
they didn't fully ruin the movie here
Green Mile that I thought myself the
ending got ruined for me and I watch it
by myself one day and I'm still dreams
even though I know it's gonna happen
cuz it's a long movie I think it's like
a three hour film Dan so you're really
put on a journey and when you're on that
journey and then you're watching the
finale take place it's very very
heartbreaking yeah that's a tearjerker
for sure when I was getting sentimental
during that clip just cuz I love Michael
Clarke Duncan and I'm this warrior man
that's a film that touches me because I
have a brother and we had like
complications in the past and stuff so
and we're both in cycle I know together
once and the sons and also their father
exactly yeah that's like an ultimate guy
cry movie I think out of any movie on
this list because this is about being a
man having a brother and issues with
your dad dude a drama that centers
around MMA league I crime speaking it's
crazy seeing footage of Tom Hardy and
joel edgerton in the ring wouldn't yeah
damn these guys are way more popular now
since this movie came out yeah this is
bad I saw this at at estimating back
before I was really millyar familiar
with the both of them it wasn't even a
heat it wasn't even that huge of a hit
but I remember people really like it's a
great movie number people liked it a lot
and when you go when you see this
footage you're like damn these guys are
so much more famous now freakin traps on
who I thought Marty has this incredible
ability to impress you with how he
changes his body
yeah the mannerisms and that was the
thing to seeing them in the ring I was
like Tom Hardy's gonna fight George and
he's like he's huge
yeah
movie forrest gump i can't really touch
home because that's one of my that's one
of the movies where people would yell at
me for not having seen it yet
I guess Forrest Gump is it is a guy I
don't know if I was gonna call it a guy
movie because like it goes so many
places and it's about like a life yeah
you know which I feel like is you know
accessible for everybody but you know
there is some stuff in it that is
definitely guy-ish there's a heavy
amount of war in it you know so there
there are things that even gents would
tear up and give each other crap about
not have a motorized vulnerability boost
whatever breath but that interstellar
mode because when I saw that scene in
interstellar like when I was actually
watching it I did tear up what he's with
thatthat slow pan and shot of him crying
or is it adding him to just focus on
it's just because it's a still shot of
him cry I mean there might be a very
slow you know tracking in but yeah for
the most part it's uninterrupted I'm so
curious how he did that scene was he
actually watching something that play a
video for him to work off of because a
lot of times when you do seems like that
on set they can't have the background
audio going yeah they need to just have
the actor there and he's like just using
his imagination purely and nothing to
really work off of because there's a
bunch of crew members behind that camera
that are like in his eyeline exactly you
know so I'm really wondering how they
got that shot damn that for that
reaction video whoever put that together
with the four so when they put the force
awakens clip in there that is totally
forever change that moment for me
because now I just and I'm laughing
everybody that's when that first popped
up I was sort of thinking isn't that a
guy crush you know I got really into the
crazy analyst yeah yeah this is like a
sci-fi epic the thing is like there's
that one sequence I think that you ride
during I remember being very impacted
very very overtaken by them Good Will
Hunting who dishonestly seemed like that
snippet of a moment I was just like okay
I think
any movie here that's why the one I
relate with the most because I've been
in therapy for many years and I've had
my breakthroughs that specific scene you
know it's not your phone because a lot
of the time when you hold on to a lot of
weight you blame yourself for so many
things so something as simple as a
repetition of it's not your fault the
affirmation of that being instilled in
him and him resisting it because like
holding on to the weight of
responsibility and blame and stuff has
been part of a way to suppress how he
really feels and that breakthrough like
that is it's one of the most beautifully
acted moments in all the movie history
for me both Robin Williams and Matt
Damon in that scene that's a beautiful
beautiful that seemed definitely oh that
gets to my heart every single time I
couldn't have said it better if I wanted
to I haven't seen Brian's song but I did
you know you get him with a mustache
that James Caan and Billy Dee Williams
did not get along on set that really
James Caan was the actual real rape not
just made he decided to sign on despite
his intent hatred that's me providing
context or a movie I haven't seen I
would like to see it sometime I feel
like it is a good one to watch it must
be good to be a like a made-for-tv
movies that goes on maybe they're like
that people love it we got to put her to
the beers
I mean that doesn't happen everyday for
a made-for-tv film that seems like a
prime choice for list like and I haven't
seen Field of Dreams has a kid I
honestly don't even remember it I don't
know I feel like that's a guy movie I
don't never know was it me try that's
another one of those like men's dramas
yeah little man drama you know where
it's not even it doesn't have like a
genre element aside from like thoughtful
fantasy to draw on you know it's not
because like interstellar to me is like
I don't think of it first when I think
of guy crime movies because I mostly
think of it as like a sci-fi epic right
you know weird but Field of Dreams yeah
- guys like kidding and touch with his
family and his and his grandfather and
the history of baseball past and all
sorts say it's been a while since I've
seen you - but yeah this is this is
prime I wonder what it would be like
watching it as a he's more of an adult
because the last time I saw it was at
least 10 years ago it seems like a prime
choice Pursuit of Happyness could have
bid on here it's about a dad and his son
and it's like a guy movie and in some
ways like a man they mean wouldn't be I
don't think I like you just put it on
with you there are stellar stars like
psy in ER so it has the sci-fi edge
that's the thing is like now I'm Green
Mile though 3 miles not a guy movie I
feel like you know lists like this one
you are inevitably gonna have a couple
that youth find questionable and a
couple you're like that fits the bill my
head so yeah I feel I'm not gonna try
and talk you out of it - all right well
thanks Ange interpreting for requesting
that my friends man good request man
that I thought led to some good
discussion for John and I to have have
you cried during all these films yeah do
you cry Andrew the kind of guy who cries
you cry well you guys can subscribe to
the real rejects subscribe to
watchmojo.com if you liked and that John
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram and of
course check out our patreon
wonderful stuff on there become a
patreon eject a guy